مساء الخير،
كان يقول :
"لا أبالي إن كنت في جانب،
والجميع في جانب آخر،
ولا أحزن،
إن ارتفعت أصواتهم أو لمعت سيوفهم.
ولا أجزع،
إن خذلني من يؤمن بما أقول.
ولا أفزع،
إن هاجمني من يفزع لما أقول.
وإنما يؤرّقني أشد الأرق،
أن لا تصل هذه الرسالة إلى ما قصدت.
فأنا أخاطب أصحاب الرأي لا أرباب المصالح.
وأنصار المبدأ لا محترفي المزايدة.
وقصاد الحق لا طالبي السلطان.
وأنصار الحكمة لا محبي الحكم."
إنه،
شهيد الكلمة،
الكاتب المصري فرج فودة،
الّذي مرّت منذ أيام الذكرى التاسعة والعشرون
لإغتياله برصاص الغدر الظلامي.
في مساء الثامن من شهر يونيو/جوان سنة 1992،
وعند خروجه من مكتبه بمعيّة إبنه وصديق له،
تعرّض الكاتب فرج فودة إلى طلق ناري كثيف بواسطة رشاش آلي
من طرف إرهابي ينتمي للجماعة الإسلامية،
يُدعى عبد الشافي رمضان،
ثمّ لاذ بالفرار على متن دراجة نارية،
كان يقودها ارهابي ثان يُدعى أشرف إبراهيم،
ولكنّ سائق فرج فودة،
الذي كان على عين المكان،
طارد بكل شجاعة القاتل وشريكه في الجريمة،
وصدمهما بالسيارة وأوقعهما أرضا،
وألقى جمع من المواطنين الحاضرين القبض على القاتل،
في حين فرّ الإرهابي الثاني لتلقي عليه الشرطة القبض في ما بعد.
نقلت سيارة الإسعاف المفكّر فرج فودة إلى المستشفى،
حيث قال وهو يصارع الموت:
"يعلم الله أنني ما فعلت شيئا إلا من أجل وطني."
حاول طاقم طبي مصري بقيادة نقيب الأطباء،
وجراح القلب الدكتور حمدي السيد إنقاذ حياة فرج فودة،
لكن للأسف لفظ أنفاسه الأخيرة،
بعد عملية جراحية دامت حوالي ست ساعات.
أثناء التحقيق مع الإرهابي عبد الشافي رمضان،
اعترف أنه قتل فرج فودة استنادا إلى فتوى،
للشيخ التكفيري عمر عبد الرحمن مفتي الجماعة الإسلامية،
وتقضي بقتل المرتد.
ولما سُئل أي من كتب فرج فوده استنتج منه أنه مرتد،
أجاب بأنه لم يقرأ أيا من كتبه،
لأنه لا يعرف القراءة والكتابة.
وعندما سُئل عن سبب اختيار موعد الاغتيال،
قبيل عيد الأضحى،
أجاب،
"لنحرق قلب أهله عليه أكثر"،
وأقرّ انه بمعية شركائه في الجريمة،
رسموا في البداية خطة لإغتيال فرج فودة،
إمّا بطعنه بسلاح أبيض،
أو بسكب كميّة من البنزين على جسده، وإضرام النار فيه حيّا،
قبل أن يتراجعوا ويختاروا عمليّة التصفية بالرصاص،
لأنّها الأكثر نجاعة.
فرج فودة،
قبل تنفيذ عملية إغتياله المادي بالرصاص،
تعرّض إلى عمليّة إغتيال معنوي ممنهجة،
امتدّت حوالي عشر سنوات،
حيث تداول على شيطنته وتكفيره كلّ من شيوخ الأزهر،
وجماعة الإخوان المسلمين
والتيار السلفي الوهابي.
قبل اغتياله بستة أشهر،
تم ترتيب مناظرة، ضمن فعاليات معرض القاهرة الدولي للكتاب،
في الثامن من يناير /كانون الثاني سنة 1992،
وحملت عنوان، «مصر بين الدولة الدينية والدولة المدنية»،
ودافع فيها عن الدولة المدنية:
فرج فودة و المفكّر التنويري محمد أحمد خلف الله،
بينما دافع فيها عن الدولة الدينية،
الشيخ محمد الغزالى العضو السابق فى جماعة الإخوان المسلمين،
ومأمون الهضيبى المرشد العام للجماعة،
ومحمد عمارة عضو هيئة علماء الأزهر.
وخلال المناظرة،
التي تجاوز عدد الحضور فيها الـ30 ألف شخص،
تم التحريض على فرج فوده واتهامه فى دينه وعقيدته،
وضجّت القاعة بالتكبير،
وتعالت هتافات الإخوان المسلمون
المستهجنة لخطاب فرج فوده وخلف الله،
والمستحسنة لخطاب الهضيبي وعمارة والغزالي.
وفى الثالث من شهر يونيو/جوان 1992،
أياما قليلة قبل عملية الإغتيال،
نشرت جريدة النور الإسلامية
بيانًا عن ندوة علماء الأزهر يكفر فرج فودة،
ويدعو لجنة شؤون الأحزاب لعدم الموافقة على إنشاء حزبه،
حزب المستقبل.
عند محاكمة قتلة فرج فوده امام محكمة أمن الدولة العليا،
قدم محمود مزروعة،
رئيس قسم العقائد والأديان بكلية أصول الدين بجامعة الأزهر،
و محمد الغزالي العضو السابق في جماعة الإخوان المسلمون
شهادتين امام هيئة المحكمة قالا فيهما،
ان فرج فوده مرتد وخارج عن الملّة،
وكان الهدف من هاتين الشهادتين المُضَلِّلتين،
هو تخفيف الأحكام على الإرهابيين القابعين في قفص الاتهام.
اعترف محمود مزروعة امام القاضي،
انه كان قد أفتى لهؤلاء القتلة بشرعية قتل المرتد،
وقال في شهادته ما يلي:
"إن اتصالا جاءه من شباب يدعون انتماءهم لإحدى الجماعات الإسلامية،
ويريدون استشارته في أمر عاجل،
فحدد لهم موعدا، والتقاهم،
فسألوه:
"ما حكم المرتد؟"
فأجاب: "قتله"،
ثم سألوه:
وإذا لم يقتله الحاكم؟
فأجاب قاطعا:
يكون حكم قتله في رقاب عامة المسلمين".
وأضاف أمام المحكمة
"أن فرج فودة أعلن رفضه لتطبيق الشريعة الإسلامية،
ووضع نفسه وجنّدها داعيا ومدافعا ضد الحكم بما أنزل الله،
وكان يقول:
لن أترك الشريعة تطبق مادام فيّ عِرقٌ ينبض،
ومثل هذا مرتد بإجماع المسلمين،
ولا يحتاج الأمر إلى هيئة تحكم بارتداده".
أما محمد الغزالي فقد قال في شهادته امام المحكمة:
"إن هؤلاء الشباب قتلوا شخصاً مباح الدم ومرتد،
وهو مستحق للقتل،
ففرج فودة بما قاله وفعله كان في حكم المرتد،
والمرتد مهدور الدم،
وولي الأمر هو المسؤول عن تطبيق الحد،
وأن التهمة التي ينبغي أن يحاسب عليها الشباب
الواقفون في القفص ليست هي القتل،
وإنما هي الافتئات على السلطة في تطبيق الحد".
الإفتئات على السلطة هنا،
يعني انهم تجاوزوا السلطة وطبّقوا حدا شرعيا دون استشارتها.
وعندما سأله القاضي:
«وهل هناك عقوبة للافتئات على السلطة فى الإسلام»؟
أجاب  الغزالى:
«لا أذكر أن لها عقوبة».
وعندما سأله القاضي:
«ما حكم من يجاهر برفض تطبيق الشريعة جحودًا و استهزاءً؟»
ردّ الغزالى بالآية القرآنية القائلة:
«وَمَنْ لَمْ يَحْكُمْ بِمَا أَنزَلَ اللَّهُ فَأُوْلَئِكَ هُمْ الْكَافِرُونَ»،
وفى آية أخرى: «الظَّالِمُونَ»،
وفى آية ثالثة: «الْفَاسِقُونَ».
وأضاف الغزالي؛
"إن بقاء المرتد في المجتمع يكون بمثابة جرثومة تنفث سمومها
بحض الناس على ترك الإسلام،
فيجب على الحاكم أن يقتله،
وإن لم يفعل يكون ذلك من واجب آحاد الناس".
لا يوجد مجال للشك،
ان القتلة الفعليين لفرج فوده،
هم محمود مزروعة،
ومحمد الغزالي،
ومحمد عمارة والهضيبي،
وغيرهم من تجار الدين الذين اباحوا دمه،
والقتلة الذين مثلوا امام محكمة من الدولة العليا المصرية،
ليسوا سوى أدوات تنفيذ لفتاوى هؤلاء الشيوخ.
تعالوا،
لنستمع معا لشهادة احد الإرهابيين،
الذي شارك في عملية اغتيال فرج فوده،
وهو الإرهابي الذي وفّر الرشاش الآلي،
ويدعى أبو العلا عبد ربه،
هذا الإرهابي الذي قضّى عشرين سنة في السجون المصرية،
وافرج عنه الرئيس المصري الأسبق،
الإخواني محمد مرسي سنة 2012،
ليلتحق سنة 2013 بتنظيم داعش في سورية،
حيث قُتل اثر غارة جوية للجيش السوري سنة 2017.
استمعوا جيّدا لما قال...
وتقول لي ماذا حصل...
ما حصل في ماذا؟
في فرج فودة...
في اغتيال فرج فودة... رحمه الله
اغتيل فرج فودة، بالنسبة لك رحمه الله، ولكنه بالنسبة لي هو مرتد،
اليس شخص مسلم يقول لا إله إلا الله...
هو ارتدّ، وليس بحكمي أنا والله، والله ليس بحكمي أنا، بحكم العلماء الذين أفتوا بردّته،
أنا لو تحرّكت من  تلقاء نفسي سأكون مخطئ  بنسبة  100٪،
لكن عندما تكون هناك فتوى من علماء الأزهر، وهم من قال بذلك.
علماء الأزهر قالوا لك أُحلّ دمه...
نعم قالوا هذا وفي المحكمة، لقد جاؤوا وقدّموا شهادتهم في المحكمة،
لا بد ان يكون لديك المستندات التي تدل على ذلك،
فيمكن ان اقول لك معلومة خاطئة...
انا لست ملمّة، وأقول لك على الهواء انني لست ملمّة بالتحقيقات، ولا أعرف...
تفضّل أخبرني ما الذي حصل...
أقول لك ان فرج فودة أفتى العلماء،
مثل عبد العزيز عبد الرؤوف،
والدكتور محمود مزروعة عميد كلية أصول الدين بالأزهر،
والشيخ محمد الغزالي...
وعمر عبد الرحمان...
لا عمر عبد الرحمان لا، عمر عبد الرحمان لم يكن موجودا في مصر...
عمر عبد الرحمان يمكن ان يفتي وهو في الخارج ما الإشكال في ذلك...
لم يفت...
يعني حضرتك، قلنا هل تعررفين؟ قلت لا أعرف...
إسمحي حضرتك ما دمت لا تعرفين، فعليك ان تسمعي من الذي يعرف...
المعذرة انها الأصول...
طالما قلت واعترفت منذ البداية امام المشاهدين،
انك لا تعرفين اذن عليك ان تسمعي من الذي يعرف...
انا اقول لا اعرف لأسايرك، ولتهدئة الحوار،
طبعا انا عارفة ولكنني أقول لك ذلك كي تتكلّم...
والله العظيم عمر عبد الرحمان ما أفتى بقتل فرج فودة،
انا أقسم لك بالله العظيم...المعذرة...
أنا أعرف ان محمد الغزالي قال انه مرتد ولكن لم يقل بقتله...
الدكتور مزروعة قال انه مرتد واهدروا دمه،
وصدر كتاب للشيخ عبد العظيم المطعني،
عندما ردّ الصحفيون على الدكتور محمود مزروعة،
اصدر كتابا بحكم المرتد،
وسأخبرك عن شيء أستاذة رولا، المعذرة،
حكم المرتد في الإسلام،
الذي يسب الله ويسب الرسول ويستهزئ بدين الإسلام،
حكمه هو توبته بان يقتل حدا، مثل الزاني المحصن،
الزاني المحصن عندما يقر بأنه زنى،
هو الذي يعترف،
فحده ان يقتل، فالحد هو تطهير له ، هذا حكم ربّنا...  ،
آخر العبارات التي رددها قاتل فرج فوده،
الإرهابي عبد الشافي رمضان قبل إعدامه هي الآتية ؛
"حبل المشنقة طريقي إلى الجنّة،
و قتلت فرج فودة حباً فى الله لأنه كافر،
وحتى الأزهر نفسه قال بكفره".
اذن دم المفكّر فرج فوده في رقاب شيوخ الأزهر،
وجماعة الإخوان المسلمين،
ورموز التيار السلفي الوهّابي.
لقد أُغتيل فرج فودة لأنّه كان "زرقاء اليمامة"،
التي كشفت لنا بحدّة بصرها وبصيرتها
خطورة مشروع  التمكين الّذي كان يعدّه المتأسلمون في الغرف المظلمة.
رحل فرج فودة،
وترك للمكتبة العربية عدّة عناوين،
شاهدة على ضراوة المعركة الفكرية التي خاضها ضد الظلاميين،
منها؛
كتاب "قبل السقوط"،
وكتاب "الإرهاب"،
وكتاب  "النذير"،
وكتاب"نكون أو لا نكون"،
وكتاب " الطائفية إلى أين؟"
وكتاب "حوار حول العلمانية"،
وكتاب "الملعوب"،
وأهمّها في تقديري كتاب "الحقيقة الغائبة".
كتاب "الحقيقة الغائبة" للمفكر الشهيد فرج فوده،
سيكون موضوع حلقتنا في الأسبوع القادم
على قناة أنا أفكر اذن أنا موجود...
أشكركم جزيل الشكر على المتابعة،
وعلى دعمكم للقناة ودمتم بخير.